This spring, sometime after South Carolina governor Mark Sanford publicly confessed that his soulmate was a woman in Argentina who was not his wife, which was just after the Elizabeth Edwards book tour where she talked about the child that her husband allegedly had with a woman who was not her, which was, of course, right on the heels of Jon and Kate splitting up after reports that he had an affair, which was all before Nevada senator John Ensign admitted paying $96,000 in cash to his former mistress and her husband, after her husband found out about their relationship, a writer named Jessica Pressler noticed something going on in the weddings pages of the New York Times , what the paper calls their Vows section.
今年春天，在南卡罗来纳州州长马克·桑福德公开承认他的灵魂伴侣是阿根廷一位非妻子的女性之后不久；而在那之前不久，伊丽莎白·爱德华兹刚结束了她的新书巡回宣传，谈到了她丈夫据称与另一位女性所生的孩子；当然，这一切紧随乔恩和凯特的分手报道之后，当时传闻他有外遇；而在此之前，内华达州参议员约翰·恩赛恩承认，在得知关系后，他向他以前的情妇及其丈夫支付了96,000美元现金；一位名叫杰西卡·普雷斯勒的作家注意到《纽约时报》的婚礼版面（该报称之为“誓言”专栏）发生了一些事情。
She saw that there were couples getting married who cheerfully told the newspaper, in the little write up that they do there, as part of their "meet cute" story, that the way they got together was that one of them cheated on a spouse or longtime partner.
她看到，有些夫妇在结婚时会兴高采烈地告诉报纸，在他们那篇小小的“浪漫邂逅”故事中，他们在一起的方式竟然是其中一人背叛了当时的配偶或长期伴侣。
I believe one of them says-- the headline on it is something like, it took awhile but they finally got together, and you're like, because he was having a three-year relationship with another person in the meantime.
我想其中一篇是这样说的——标题大概是“好事多磨，他们最终走到了一起”，你看了会想，那是因为他在这期间已经和另一个人保持了三年的关系。
Jessica Pressler wrote up her discovery on the New York magazine blog, "Daily Intel." She noted that there was a kind of code language in all these wedding articles.
杰西卡·普雷斯勒在《纽约》杂志的博客“每日情报”上写下了她的发现。她指出，所有这些结婚报道中都有一种暗语。
They always say, like, their road to finding each other was a bumpy road. Or, they had a difficult time, many ups and downs. They encountered some obstacles along the way. And it's like, no, those are people. Those are other lives. They're not speed bumps.
他们总是说，他们寻找彼此的道路是一条坎坷的道路。或者，他们经历了一段艰难的时期，经历了许多起伏。他们在路上遇到了一些障碍。这听起来就像是，不，那些是人。那些是其他人的生活。他们不是减速带。
Take, for instance, the married women who, according to a romantic write up on the Vows page of the New York Times , flew to Paris to see another man and stayed with him in a hotel in the Latin quarter for two weeks where they quote "reveled in their Vie Boheme" before she flew back to the US and moved out of the home in New Jersey that she shared with her husband.
比如，据《纽约时报》“誓言”版面上一篇浪漫的报道，有位已婚女性飞往巴黎去见另一个男人，并在拉丁区的一家旅馆里和他住了两周，两人引用了“沉浸在波西米亚生活中”的说法，随后她飞回美国，搬出了她与丈夫在新泽西州的家。
I mean, it's just weird because Vows is something that you have to try to get into. You have to lobby to get into that column. So it's like, Mark Sanford, he had to speak publicly about his affair. Most people don't have to go around telling everybody about it.
我的意思是，这很奇怪，因为“誓言”专栏不是随随便便就能上的。你必须费尽心机才能进入那个专栏。所以就像马克·桑福德那样，他不得不公开谈论他的外遇。大多数人不必到处向所有人宣扬这件事。
See, but that's what's so strange about it. Is that somehow, some part of them doesn't think, I shouldn't talk about this. Somehow the notion, I had an affair, is so just nothing to them.
你看，但这就是最奇怪的地方。不知何故，他们内心深处并没有觉得“我不应该谈论这件事”。某种程度上，“我有了外遇”这一念头对他们来说根本不算什么。
Right. I think it's probably just people, when they cheat on other people, tell themselves that they're doing it because they have to, because fate is involved. And whatever happened, you're better off and probably the person that you broke up with is better off. And this is the way it was meant to be. This is fate.
没错。我想可能只是人们在背叛他人时，会告诉自己这是因为他们不得不这样做，因为这是命运的安排。无论发生了什么，你过得更好，可能那个被你甩掉的人也过得更好。这就是注定的。这就是命运。
As for the cheated on ex-partner, when the story appears in the newspaper on the wedding pages, it's almost as if the newspaper is siding with the cheating couple. The ex-partner is just collateral damage on the way to their wedding.
至于那个被背叛的前伴侣，当故事出现在报纸的婚礼版面上时，就好像报纸站在了出轨夫妇这一边。前任只是他们通往婚礼道路上的附属损害。
They don't get to say anything for themselves. It's not their story anymore. It's somebody else's love story.
他们无法为自己说话。这不再是他们的故事了。这是别人的爱情故事。
But that's the thing, if it were any other section of the newspaper, the reporter would go to them too for a comment. To get their side.
但问题是，如果是报纸的其他版面，记者也会去采访他们寻求评论。去了解他们的看法。
I think they should do that.
我想他们应该这样做。
But because it's the wedding section, it's just like, well, it's not really their story.
但因为这是婚礼版面，就好像，好吧，这实际上不是他们的故事。
Right. Yeah, they have no say for themselves. They're done. This had nothing to do with them. It's very bizarre. It raises all kinds of questions for me. As a reader, I'm very distracted by it.
没错。是的，他们没有发言权。他们出局了。这和他们完全没关系。这非常离奇。这引发了我心中的各种疑问。作为一个读者，我被这种事情分心了。
Well, today on our radio program, we go where the newspaper marriage columns fear to tread. We hear from all parties to the affair, the cheated on, as well as the cheaters, and their differing takes on what happened. And, no surprise, they are very different from one another's. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show: "Infidelity." Stay with us.
好了，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们去触碰那些报纸婚姻专栏不敢涉及的地方。我们听听外遇各方的声音，包括被背叛者，以及出轨者，听听他们对所发生事情的不同看法。而且，不出所料，他们的说法大相径庭。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是：“不忠”。请继续收听。
"Let me kiss your stiff upper lip." We begin with this story from England, which, if you've read any 19th century literature, seems to be an island that is filled entirely with people who are full of submerged and often misplaced passions for other people. Here's Ruby Wright.
“让我吻吻你那坚毅的嘴唇。”我们从这个来自英国的故事开始，如果你读过任何19世纪的文学作品，就会发现这个岛屿似乎充满了那些对他人怀有隐秘且往往错位激情的人。这是鲁比·赖特。
Andrew, you've always lived in Dorset?
安德鲁，你一直住在多塞特郡吗？
Yeah.
是的。
But why did you end up in this part of Dorset?
那你为什么会搬到多塞特郡的这一带呢？
I was looking for a house for myself and my two daughters, somewhere to live. I always wanted to live in the countryside, having always lived in the towns in Dorset. And I saw it in the paper. It's as simple as that.
当时我在为自己和两个女儿找房子，找个地方住。我一直想住在乡下，因为我之前一直住在多塞特郡的城镇里。我在报纸上看到了这个消息。事情就是这么简单。
And you didn't know anyone around here?
那你在这附近认识什么人吗？
No.
不认识。
So how did you know about us?
那你怎么知道我们的？
I was at the pub. And this couple walks in, and the bloke was wearing a leopard-skinned pillbox hat and I thought, I've got to get to know this person. And he had a very attractive wife, I think that was-- I just saw them in the pub and thought, I must know these people.
当时我在酒吧里。这对夫妇走进来，那个男的戴着一顶豹纹皮盒式女帽，我想，我一定要认识这个人。而且他有一位非常有吸引力的妻子，我想就是那样……我只是在酒吧里看到他们，心想，我一定要认识这些人。
This guy, Andrew, moved to the village. And he'd met us both together, at the same time, in the pub. And I would say that we both had a closeness to Andrew. My closeness to Andrew was very much about talking about how I felt and how he felt. And he would have various unsuitable girlfriends. He'd have flings with people. And I'd say, come on, then Andrew, tell me about it. I liked it, he was very candid.
这个叫安德鲁的家伙搬到了村子里。他在酒吧里同时认识了我们俩。我想说，我们俩和安德鲁都很亲近。我和安德鲁的亲近很大程度上是在交流彼此的感受。他会有各种不合适的女性朋友。他会和人玩玩暧昧。我会说，来吧，安德鲁，告诉我。我喜欢这样，他非常坦诚。
I was a single parent at the time, and it just seemed an idyllic situation. A beautiful old cottage with this couple, and their daughter living in it. And it was a home from home, became a home from home for me.
那时我是一个单亲家长，这看起来是个田园诗般的情况。一栋漂亮的老房子，住着这对夫妇和他们的女儿。这对我来说成了一个避风港。
And you became a very good friend. And I remember, you'd come up a lot, and we'd come down and see you. And you were always a very cozy person to have around. It was always a delight when you used to come up and see us.
而你成了一个非常好的朋友。我记得你经常来，我们也常去见你。和你在一起总是很舒心。你来见我们总是令人高兴的事。
Yes. I would argue that I'd fallen in love with the whole family. Including you and Ed, indeed, at that point.
是的。我会说我爱上了这一整家人。当然，那时也包括你和埃德。
When I started to fall in love with Andrew, it was like my falling in love with him was a direct parallel of my father dying. So as my father was dying at home of cancer, I was falling deeper and deeper in love with this man Andrew. And Andrew would talk to me about my father dying because he'd been with his mother, who died of a brain tumor. He'd actually been beside her bed with her, as she died, and during that period. And I think I valued being with someone. Because George's parents were both still very much alive at that point. I think, for me, it was sort of-- I felt he had an understanding of what it was like. And it was very hard for me not to fall in love with him.
当我开始爱上安德鲁时，就像我爱上他与我父亲的去世在时间上是平行的。当我的父亲在家里因癌症去世时，我正越来越深地爱上安德鲁这个男人。安德鲁会和我谈论我父亲的去世，因为他也经历过他母亲因脑瘤去世的过程。在他母亲去世期间，他实际上一直守在她的病床边。我想我很看重能和这样一个人在一起。因为那时乔治的父母都还健在。我想对我来说，这是一种……我觉得他了解那是什么感觉。很难不爱上他。
Did you think something was always going to happen?
你觉得最终会发生什么吗？
No. I was convinced nothing would happen. I had fallen in love with her, so probably over the summer after her father's death, I was single at the time, just living with Tams, my younger daughter. And I didn't really want a partner at the time. So falling in love with Lal, I thought, that's OK. I can love somebody from afar, and I don't need to love anyone else. And it had never occurred to me that she might even dream of falling in love with me. It just didn't occur to me that Lal might look at anyone other than George.
没有。我确信什么都不会发生。我爱上了她，所以可能在她父亲去世后的那个夏天，那时我单身，只和小女儿塔姆斯住在一起。当时我并不真的想要一个伴侣。所以爱上拉尔，我想，那没关系。我可以远远地爱着一个人，不需要爱上别人。我甚至从未想过她可能会梦想着爱上我。拉尔除了乔治以外还会看别人，这件事我连想都没想过。
How did I know? Well, I'd come back from this trip, and it was Christmas. And Lal said, "We're going to spend Christmas with Andrew." And I was delighted, because I couldn't think of anybody nicer to spend Christmas with. And I remember Andrew coming up the evening I got back. I was going off to get the present for him that I'd bought. I thought, that's odd, Lal and Andrew are not talking to each other. There's silence in the kitchen. And when he left, he kissed her on the back of the head. And I just-- something, I don't know, maybe I was-- one part of me was expecting something to happen one of these days. It was confirmed, because mum has left her diary lying around. And I read it, and there it was.
我怎么知道的？嗯，我那次旅行回来，刚好是圣诞节。拉尔说：“我们要和安德鲁一起过圣诞节。”我很高兴，因为我想不出还有谁比他更适合一起过圣诞节。我记得我回来那天晚上安德鲁过来了。我正要去找我买给他的礼物。我想，真奇怪，拉尔和安德鲁怎么不说话了。厨房里一片寂静。当他离开时，他吻了吻她的后脑勺。我只是……有些……我不知道，也许我……我的一部分在预料着这些天会发生什么事。这得到了证实，因为妈妈把日记丢在外面了。我读了它，事情就是那样。
So it was like she wanted you to find out without having to say it.
所以好像她希望你发现，而不必亲口说出来。
I think, yes.
我想是的。
And you actually had to tell me. Were you going to tell me together?
而你实际上不得不告诉我。你们打算一起告诉我吗？
Yes. We were going to tell you-- I don't think we'd even discussed telling you. But what happened was, you had been away on a holiday and had come home. And I picked you up, I think. And you said to me, "Where is mum?" And I thought, what am I going to tell Ruby? I have probably half a minute to decide. Am I going to tell her the truth or am I going to make up some story? And I thought-- I just said to you, "Well, I think she's down at Andrew's." And I didn't have to say any more. You seemed to know.
是的。我们打算告诉你……我想我们甚至没讨论过要告诉你。但后来发生的事是，你出去度假刚回来。我想是我去接你的。你对我说：“妈妈在哪里？”我心想，我该怎么告诉鲁比？我大概有半分钟的时间来决定。我是告诉她真相还是编个故事？我想……我只是对你说：“嗯，我想她在安德鲁那儿。”我不用再多说什么了。你好像已经知道了。
You were very angry with me, quite rightly. And I think up until that point, we had always had a very close relationship. And your anger manifested itself mostly by you just refusing to see me.
你当时非常生我的气，这是理所当然的。我想在那之前，我们一直保持着非常亲密的关系。而你的愤怒主要表现为你拒绝见我。
I think people were very shocked by what happened. And I was very shocked. And Dad was very shocked. Were you surprised at yourself? Or were you surprised at the force of your own attraction and actions?
我想人们对发生的事情感到非常震惊。我也很震惊。爸爸也很震惊。你对自己感到惊讶吗？还是对你自己那种吸引力和行动的力量感到惊讶？
I am shocked now at how incredibly selfishly I acted. And how oblivious I was to your pain and George's pain and Ed's pain. Almost like I deserved this thing, I was on this track and I was heading off on it and nothing was going to deter me. But as to say, almost as if I deserved it. Almost as if I was owed it.
我现在对我的行为竟然如此自私感到震惊。我对你、乔治和埃德的痛苦竟然如此毫无察觉。就像我理应得到这一切，我走在这条轨道上，正朝着它前进，没有什么能阻止我。但正如我所说，几乎就像我理应得到它。几乎就像这是我应得的一样。
George was tipped off. And I felt-- as soon as I knew, I felt I had to go and face him. So I walked up to Manitoba and I can remember standing outside, in the bottom field, for a good half an hour, summoning up the courage to go and say to George, "This is true." I'd expected, quite literally expected him to hit me or bloody my nose or something like that. Or at least shout at me, or rave. I knocked on the door, he said, "Oh, Andrew. Andrew, come in. Come in. Have a glass of wine."
乔治得到了风声。我感觉到……一旦我知道了，我觉得我必须去面对他。所以我走到马尼托巴，我记得我站在外面，在底部的田野里，站了足足半个小时，鼓起勇气去对乔治说：“这是真的。”我曾预料，真的预料他会打我，或者把我的鼻子打出血之类的。或者至少对我大喊大叫，或者咆哮。我敲了敲门，他说：“哦，安德鲁。安德鲁，进来。进来。喝杯红酒吧。”
Five minutes later I was in floods of tears, and George wasn't. It's just very odd. It was all kind of wrong. But what he said to me stayed with me, until now really, he said, "Andrew, I've lost my partner. I don't want to lose my best friend."
五分钟后我泪流满面，而乔治却没有。这真是太奇怪了。这一切都有点不对劲。但他对我说的那些话一直留在我的心里，直到现在，他说：“安德鲁，我失去了我的伴侣。我不想失去我最好的朋友。”
I know I have a real problem with anger. I mean, I don't tend to get angry. I find it a very hard emotion to express. But I was angry at that point. I was very angry. I remember standing at the sink doing the drying up and somehow the plates ended up being smashed on the floor. The emotions were very, very odd because I was terribly, terribly fond of Andrew and he was very concerned about my well-being.
我知道我在愤怒问题上确实有困难。我的意思是，我不倾向于发火。我发现这是一种很难表达的情绪。但在那时我确实很生气。我非常生气。我记得站在水槽边洗盘子，不知怎么的，盘子最后全摔在了地上。那种情绪非常非常古怪，因为我非常非常喜欢安德鲁，他也很关心我的健康。
At that point I still believed, strongly, that we would all become friends again. I'm looking back and it's all terribly naive, really. But that's what I felt at the time, so I wanted to keep some kind of relationship going with George for this future, blissful time when we were all friends again.
在那一刻，我仍然坚信我们所有人都会重新成为朋友。回头看，这真的很天真。但那是当时我的感受，所以我希望能和乔治保持某种关系，为了未来那个我们又成了朋友的幸福时光。
I think in my fantasy world, I would have carried on having a passionate, physical, sexual relationship with Andrew and a fond relationship with George. And the two would have somehow run together. I think some couples, through all their anger or hatred or battles, there's this incredible chemistry that still comes back. To your irritation, you can't get rid of this-- and I think with George somehow for me the chemistry disappeared quite early on.
我想在我的幻想世界里，我会继续和安德鲁保持激情、身体和性方面的关系，并和乔治保持深厚的感情。两者会以某种方式并行。我想有些夫妻，经历了所有的愤怒、仇恨或争吵，仍然有一种不可思议的化学反应。让你恼火的是，你无法摆脱这种——我想对我和乔治来说，化学反应很早就消失了。
I mean, the one thing we haven't discussed in all of this, you know, the question of sex. I mean, that was really at the heart of our split up. That mum did not-- she was not satisfied in that department. And I knew that I had a part in this. That there was an aspect of our relationship, namely the sexual part of it, that I wasn't facing up to.
我的意思是，我们在这一切中还没有讨论的一件事，就是性问题。我的意思是，那确实是我们分手的核心所在。妈妈没有——她在那个部门并不满足。我知道我在其中有一份责任。我们的关系中有一个方面，即性方面，我一直没有面对。
That I had a responsibility in it. I wasn't an innocent victim, as it were.
我在这方面是有责任的。我并不是一个所谓的无辜受害者。
You could say that George loved Lal, he could understand me loving Lal. And whilst that was contrary to his needs or wishes or whatever, he could understand it. In a sense, I think he never blamed me. I think he blamed Lal and not me.
你可以说乔治爱拉尔，他能理解我爱拉尔。虽然这违背了他的需要或愿望之类的，但他能理解。在某种意义上，我想他从未责怪我。我想他责怪的是拉尔而不是我。
It got very complicated because George and Andrew, far from becoming rivals and having a duel at dawn-- far from George challenging Andrew to a duel at dawn, George kind of welcomed Andrew into the fold, and Andrew became a kind of member of my family, but without me there. And there would be Sunday lunches and Saturday suppers and dances in Evershot. He was part of that. And, of course, I felt like I was living in exile. I felt like I'd been exiled to this foreign country, albeit a beautiful one and it was six miles away. But I felt I couldn't have been further away.
事情变得非常复杂，因为乔治和安德鲁，远没有成为竞争对手并举行黎明决斗——远没有乔治向安德鲁发出黎明决斗的挑战，乔治反而把安德鲁迎进了这个圈子，安德鲁成了我家的一员，但却是在没有我的情况下。会有周日的午餐、周六的晚餐和埃弗肖特的舞会。他是其中的一部分。当然，我觉得自己被流放了。我觉得我被流放到这个外国，尽管它很美，而且离这里只有六英里远。但我感觉我不可能离得更远了。
And Andrew was welcomed into the bosom of the family. And I think that caused enormous resentment for me. I know it did. And I don't know whether Andrew ever understood that, what it was like, on a Sunday, to know that he was having lunch with my daughter and my son and my ex-partner. And I was here.
安德鲁被全家人欣然接纳。我想这引起了我的极大愤慨。我知道确实如此。我不知道安德鲁是否理解这一点，在周日，知道他和我的女儿、儿子以及前任共进午餐时，那是一种什么样的感觉。而我却在这里。
What then happened was that mum's relationship with Andrew didn't last. And I still continued to see Andrew because he lived just around the corner. And I know that she found that incredibly hard. That when, despite the fact that she wasn't seeing Andrew, that I still was his friend. And she felt excluded from my new life. I didn't think she had much right.
后来发生的事是妈妈和安德鲁的关系没有持续下去。但我仍然继续见安德鲁，因为他就住在街角。我知道她觉得这极其困难。尽管她已经不再见安德鲁，但我仍然是他的朋友。她觉得被我的新生活排斥在外了。我不认为她有什么权利。
I've heard people say that it's impossible to have a relationship. You can't stay with the person you leave your family for, because there's too much guilt and emotion. Do you think the fact that you left George for Andrew ultimately meant that you couldn't continue this relationship with him?
我听过人们说，维持这种关系是不可能的。你无法和你为了他而离开家庭的人在一起，因为有太多的内疚和情绪。你认为你为了安德鲁而离开乔治的事实，最终意味着你无法继续这段关系吗？
Yes, I do. I don't think it's impossible. But I think it was, if not inevitable, it was quite likely that those seeds of destruction that were laid right at the beginning, and blame did, in the end, undermine our relationship.
是的，我是这么认为的。我不认为这是不可能的。但我认为，如果不是不可避免的，那些从一开始就种下的毁灭种子和指责，最终还是破坏了我们的关系。
Do you wish that you could turn the clock back?
你希望时光倒流吗？
No, because, at that point, I think I was still completely obsessed with Andrew. This idea that love being a madness. So I don't think at that point I did wish I could -- I think it was much later, I would wake, in the night, with the window on the wrong side of the room, sometime around dawn or before dawn, I think. I'd just think, what am I doing in this place? How have I got here? And it was as if I'd sleepwalked out of my other life, with no explanation, and I'd woken up and here I was. And it was truly terrifying.
不，因为在那个时候，我想我仍然完全痴迷于安德鲁。那种认为爱情是一种疯狂的想法。所以我不认为在那个时候我希望我可以——我想那是很久以后的事了，我会在夜里醒来，窗户在房间错误的另一边，大概在黎明时分或黎明前。我想。我只会想，我在这个地方做什么？我是怎么到这里的？就好像我梦游般走出了我的另一段生活，没有任何解释，然后我醒了，我就在这里。这真的很可怕。
And I think that, as long as I was damaging you lot, I was really not aware. But it was when I came to damage myself, that was when I really woke up.
而且我想，只要我在伤害你们，我就真的没有意识到。但当我开始伤害我自己时，我才真正醒悟。
Because I lost you. Effectively, I lost you between the ages of 13 and 18. So my biggest loss was losing you for five years. At puberty. You were 13, you were just about to have your first period. You went off with George to Africa. You came back and you looked different. And, actually, with maternal intuition-- which I obviously didn't have much of-- I remember looking at you and thinking, she's changed. She started her period. She's becoming a young woman. And, sure enough, you told me. And I thought, God, George was there for that. Her dad was there for that. Why wasn't I there for that?
因为我失去了你。实际上，我在你13岁到18岁之间失去了你。所以我最大的损失是在青春期失去了你五年。你13岁了，正要迎来第一次月经。你和乔治去了非洲。你回来时看起来不一样了。而且，凭借母亲的直觉——我显然没有多少这种直觉——我记得看着你，心想，她变了。她开始来月经了。她正在成长为一个年轻女性。果不其然，你告诉了我。我想，天哪，乔治在那儿见证了这一切。她的爸爸在那儿见证了这一切。为什么我不在那儿？
And I think during that whole time, we didn't really talk about how we felt, did we?
我想在那整段时间里，我们都没有真正谈论过我们的感受，对吧？
No, I don't think so.
不，我不这么认为。
Ruby Wright. She does a music show called Ruby's Chicky Boil-Ups. It airs every other Sunday on radionowhere.org. Her website is rubywright-- that's W-R-I-G-H-T-- dot com.
鲁比·赖特。她主持一个名为“Ruby's Chicky Boil-Ups”的音乐节目。每隔一个周日在radionowhere.org上播出。她的网站是rubywright——即W-R-I-G-H-T——点com。
Coming up, what to say to your parents about the rich, married guy who set you up in an apartment when you're 22 years old. And what to say to yourself. And other dilemmas of cheaters and the cheated on. In a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，当你22岁时，该如何告诉父母关于那个把你安置在公寓里的有钱已婚男人。以及该如何对自己说。还有出轨者和被背叛者的其他困境。稍后。节目将从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show: "Infidelity." Recently, when CNN did a story about Elizabeth Edwards, it was interesting to read the comments on CNN's website. There were nearly 300 comments, a lot of them just vicious. Calling her crazy, calling her delusional, calling her an idiot, to stay with her husband, John Edwards. But a few women wrote in to say, it all seemed more complicated than that.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目：“不忠”。最近，当CNN报道伊丽莎白·爱德华兹时，阅读CNN网站上的评论很有意思。有近300条评论，其中很多纯属恶意。称她疯了，称她产生幻觉，称她是个白痴，竟然还要和她丈夫约翰·爱德华兹在一起。但一些女性写道，这一切似乎比那复杂得多。
One posted this: "I am in this situation right now. It's a difficult call to make." My mom was a psychologist, and she specialized in couples where somebody had cheated. She treated hundreds of these couples, and she did studies looking at hundreds more. She wrote a book about her findings. There is solid research, a variety of researchers have shown, that in one out of two couples, one or both partners will cheat during the lifetime of a relationship. That's 50% percent of all relationships.
其中一位写道：“我现在就处于这种情况。这是一个艰难的决定。”我妈妈是一位心理学家，她专门研究有人出轨的夫妻。她治疗过数百对这样的夫妇，并对另外数百对进行了研究。她写了一本书来记录她的发现。有可靠的研究，多位研究人员表明，在每两对夫妻中，就有一对或双方会在关系期间出轨。这是所有关系的50%。
Most affairs are never detected. And one of the surprising things that my mom found out in her research was that tons of people will have affairs even though they're happy in their marriage. You don't have to be unhappy to have an affair. 56% of the men and 34% of the women in one of my mom's studies said they cheated though their marriage was happy. And she said lots of couples came in to see where that was the situation.
大多数外遇从未被发现。我妈妈在研究中发现的一个令人惊讶的事情是，很多人即使在婚姻中感到幸福也会有外遇。你不必不快乐就会有外遇。在我妈妈的一项研究中，56%的男性和34%的女性表示，尽管他们的婚姻很幸福，他们还是出轨了。她说很多夫妻来到这里，就是这种情况。
Where not only the cheated on partner, but the cheater seemed genuinely surprised that this had happened in their marriage. Which brings us to our next story. About the cheaters lurking inside any relationship. We're at Act 2 of our show, Act 2, "The Italian Job." This story comes from James Braly, who told it at the storytelling series, The Moth, in front of a live audience.
不仅是被背叛的伴侣，连出轨者似乎也对婚姻中发生的这种事感到真诚的惊讶。这把我们引向了下一个故事。关于潜伏在任何关系中的出轨者。我们现在来到节目的第二幕，第二幕，“意大利任务”。这个故事来自詹姆斯·布拉利，他在现场观众面前的讲故事系列“飞蛾”中讲述了这个故事。
I am sitting on my suitcase in the main train station in Rome next to my girlfriend, Susan, who's sitting on hers. And we're rifling through our Let's Go: Europe , trying to agree on the next destination of our vacation. Susan grew up in Germany, so she'll go basically anyplace. As long as it's sunny. But I need to go to the right place. And I have a pathological terror of going to the wrong place.
我坐在罗马火车站的行李箱上，旁边是坐在她行李箱上的女朋友苏珊。我们正在翻阅我们的《Let's Go: Europe》，试图商定度假的下一个目的地。苏珊在德国长大，所以她基本上去哪里都行。只要是晴天就行。但我需要去正确的地方。我对去错误的地方有着病态的恐惧。
So, whenever Susan suggests someplace in particular, I suggest someplace else. Because I can see something wrong with every place. And this is a gift I bring to every area of my life, notably my relationship with Susan. We've been together for about seven years since college, and every time she brings up the subject of commitment-- maybe it's a good time to get married-- I say, I think I need a little more time just to make sure that what we're doing is right.
所以，每当苏珊建议去某个特定地方时，我就建议去别的地方。因为我能看出每个地方都有问题。这是我带给生活各个领域的礼物，特别是与苏珊的关系。大学毕业后我们在一起大约七年了，每次她提到承诺的问题——也许是结婚的好时机——我说，我想我需要多一点时间来确保我们所做的是正确的。
So, as a result, all of the lights on the arrivals and departures board are blinking. And the man on the public address system keeps saying departzione over and over and over again. And Susan is up on her feet, screaming at me, "Make up your mind before all the trains pull out."
所以，结果是，到达和出发牌上的所有灯都在闪烁。广播系统中的那个人一遍又一遍地说着“出发”。苏珊跳了起来，对我尖叫道：“在火车全开走之前做决定。”
While I am kind of hypnotized by the hem of this flower print dress, it's about 10 feet away, fluttering in the breeze each time a train pulls in or out of the station. Which, at this point, is frequently. Which is hanging off what may be the most beautiful woman I have ever seen, who is standing next to her beautiful friend. When Susan says, "Are you looking at those women?" And I say, "Where?"
虽然我被这条花印裙子的下摆催眠了，它离我大约10英尺远，每次火车进站或出站时都在微风中飘动。此时，频率很高。它挂在可能是我见过最漂亮的女人身上，她站在她漂亮的朋友旁边。当苏珊说：“你在看那些女人吗？”我说：“哪里？”
And she says, "Right there, in the flower print dresses." And I say, "You mean them?" And she says, "Yes. They look interesting, don't they? Like maybe they're going someplace interesting we might want to go. You know what? I think I'll ask them." And before I can tell her what a bad idea that is, she's over there talking to them in French. And they're pointing at me, and a few minutes later she's introducing them to me.
她说：“就在那里，穿花印裙子的那些。”我说：“你是说她们？”她说：“是的。她们看起来很有趣，不是吗？就像她们要去某个我们可能想去的有趣地方。你知道吗？我想我去问问她们。”在我还没来得及告诉她这主意有多糟糕之前，她已经过去用法语和她们交谈了。她们指着我，几分钟后她就把她们介绍给我了。
Isabel is the beautiful one and her sister is a gloriously beautiful woman named Franz, who has a face off of one of those French go to war, buy war bonds posters that makes you want to invade. So I'm just staring at her as Susan says, "Guess what, James? They're going to Positano." Which is one of the numerous fishing villages we debated going to. "What do you say we all travel together?"
伊莎贝尔是漂亮的那个，她的姐妹是一位名叫弗兰茨的绝世美人，她的脸就像那些法国参加战争、购买战争债券的海报上的脸，让你想去入侵。所以我只是盯着她，苏珊说：“猜怎么着，詹姆斯？她们要去波西塔诺。”这是我们讨论过的众多渔村之一。“我们要不要一起去旅行？”
And two minutes later Franz and I are on the same vacation. Sitting on a train to Naples, and then on a hydrofoil to Positano, and then checking into the same hotel, into adjacent rooms where we're going to change into our swimsuits and meet on the beach. Now, I haven't been in a swimsuit for years, since the last time I was on the beach. And I'm looking in the mirror in the hotel and things have changed since then.
两分钟后，弗兰茨和我开始了同一场假期。坐在去那不勒斯的火车上，然后坐水翼船去波西塔诺，然后入住同一家酒店，进入相邻的房间，我们要换上泳衣在海滩上见面。现在，我已经很多年没穿泳衣了，自从上次去海滩以来。我在酒店照镜子，从那时起事情发生了变化。
A little Italian bakery opened up around the corner from my office. And I'd been going there every workday, having apricot bear claws. And now I have two apricot bear claws hanging off the sides of my waist, bubbling up over my swimsuit. And it's one thing to decay in front of your girlfriend, there is a kind of mutual decay contract, where you are all going to atrophy at more or less the same rate.
我办公室拐角处开了一家小意大利面包店。我每个工作日都去那里，吃杏子熊爪饼。现在我的腰两边有两个挂着的杏子熊爪饼，在泳衣上鼓起来了。在女朋友面前衰老是一回事，有一种相互衰老的契约，即你们都将以大致相同的速度萎缩。
But I don't have that deal with Franz. And there's no way she's seeing my bear claws. So when we meet on the beach, the girls are in French bikinis. And I'm in my shorts and my button down shirt from the train ride, like I forgot to undress half myself. And after a couple hours of them swimming, Franz comes over to me and says, "Do you not swim?" And I say, "Indoors. I burn easily." And she hands me her bottle of sunblock. And I start to shake my head sadly, and point to one of the ingredients, and I say, "I'm allergic."
但我没有和弗兰茨签署那个协议。她绝不能看到我的熊爪。所以当我们下海滩时，女孩们穿着法国比基尼。我穿着火车上穿的短裤和扣子衬衫，就像我忘了把自己脱光一样。她们游了几个小时后，弗兰茨走到我身边说：“你不游泳吗？”我说：“在室内。我很容易晒伤。”她把防晒霜递给我。我开始悲伤地摇头，指着其中一种成分，说：“我过敏。”
There are six more days to go. So, the next morning, after an all nighter with Let's Go: Europe , I have a comprehensive understanding of all the cultural high points within a 30-mile radius of the city of Positano. None of which include the beach. There is Mount Vesuvius and the Grottoes of Capri and the Hanging Gardens at Ravenna. And we can go to a beach anywhere, but there's only so many places you can see this kind of culture. That's the position I'm taking.
还有六天时间。所以，第二天早上，熬了一整晚阅读《Let's Go: Europe》之后，我对波西塔诺市半径30英里内的所有文化高点有了全面的了解。其中没有一个包括海滩。有维苏威火山、卡普里岛的洞穴和拉文纳的空中花园。我们可以在任何地方去海滩，但只有少数地方能看到这种文化。这就是我的立场。
And the French love culture. And the Germans admire the French.
法国人热爱文化。德国人钦佩法国人。
So six days later, we're all just about as pasty as when we stepped off the hydrofoil. My secret waist is still a secret. And I make it to the last night, we have a little farewell dinner at a seaside restaurant and we're walking on the beach one last time, for old time's sake. Saying our goodbyes. Everyone is a little misty. Except me. I can't wait to go home in the morning.
所以六天后，我们都像刚下水翼船时一样苍白。我的秘密腰部仍然是个秘密。我撑到了最后一晚，我们在海边的餐厅吃了一顿告别晚餐，最后一次在海滩上散步，为了往日的情分。告别。每个人都有点伤感。除了我。我迫不及待地想在早上回家。
When Franz says, "Does anyone want to go swimming?" And her relatively more modest sister says, "We don't have suits." And fearless, guileless, dramatic Susan says, "That's OK with me." And a couple of minutes later, they're standing on the beach in panties and bras. Which are very different than bikinis. And Franz's are chocolate brown lace. Her skin is the color of milk. She looks like a profiterole. My favorite dessert.
弗兰茨说：“有人想去游泳吗？”她相对保守一点的姐妹说：“我们没带泳衣。”无所畏惧、天真、戏剧性的苏珊说：“我没关系。”几分钟后，她们站在海滩上，穿着内裤和胸罩。这与比基尼大不相同。弗兰茨的是巧克力色的蕾丝。她的皮肤像牛奶一样。她看起来像泡芙。我最喜欢的甜点。
It is agony to keep my eyes open, but I can't close them. And the three of them run into the water, laughing and splashing, and then finally disappearing underneath the surface. So everything is quiet for a moment and then one, two, three, they pop up and start calling at me, like sirens. Who actually lived in Positano 3,000 years ago. "James, come in. It's wonderful."
睁开眼睛是一种折磨，但我无法闭上它们。她们三个笑着嬉闹着跑进水里，最后消失在水面下。所以一切安静了一会儿，然后一、二、三，她们弹了出来，像塞壬一样呼唤我。那些3000年前真正住在波西塔诺的人。“詹姆斯，进来。这太美妙了。”
I haven't been swimming one time, and it's dark. So I make a decision. I'm going to take off my shoes and socks and pants and I put them on a beach chair. And I unbutton my shirt and thread out my arms so that it's just hanging there like a little poncho. And when Franz disappears into the water again, it goes off on the back of a beach chair and I'm in. But I've waited so long to make up my mind that Susan's cold. Franz's sister is ready to go back as well. But Franz is fine, and I just got in, and we're all vacation buddies.
我一次都没游过，而且天黑了。所以我做了一个决定。我要脱下鞋子、袜子和裤子，把它们放在沙滩椅上。我解开衬衫，把手臂抽出来，让它像小斗篷一样挂着。当弗兰茨再次消失在水中时，它落在了沙滩椅的背上，我进去了。但我做决定等了太久，苏珊感到了寒冷。弗兰茨的姐妹也准备回去了。但弗兰茨很好，我刚进去，我们都是度假伙伴。
So Susan and the sister go back to the hotel, leaving Franz and I, for first time, alone. In the dark, in our underwear, in the Mediterranean, where they invented the word "philander." And, where it occurs to me, we can have sex without her seeing my body. So I swim around for a little bit, and trying to figure out what's the personal space in the Mediterranean. How close can you swim before you can't swim away?
所以苏珊和姐妹回酒店了，留下了我和弗兰茨，第一次，单独在一起。在黑暗中，穿着内衣，在地中海，在那里他们发明了“风流”这个词。而且，我意识到，我们可以发生性关系而不用让她看到我的身体。所以我游了一会儿，试图弄清楚在地中海的个人空间是什么。在游不动之前你能游多近？
And whatever that distance is, Franz swims right to the edge of it and says, "The water makes me feel so free." It's not having that effect on me. I got bear claws to hide and promises to keep. And I am so tense that I can't breathe normally, which makes me look abnormal. Which leads Franz to say, "Is everything OK? Maybe we should go back." And she gets out of the water, and stands on the beach dripping in the moonlight, dabbing at herself with her dress.
无论那个距离是多少，弗兰茨游到了边缘，说：“水让我感到如此自由。”这对我没起作用。我有熊爪要隐藏，有承诺要遵守。而且我太紧张了，无法正常呼吸，这让我看起来不正常。这导致弗兰茨说：“一切还好吗？也许我们该回去了。”她从水里出来，站在月光下滴水的海滩上，用裙子擦拭身体。
So I've got one eye on her, and the other on my shirt, which is fluttering off the back of this chair. And I get closer and closer, spreading my legs wider and wider, so that only my head is visible. Like an alligator. It looks like I'm in about six feet of water, but really it's about 18 inches. My thighs are in agony, and I can't hold out much longer, when Franz lifts her dress, over her head and I spring up on the beach and behind the chair and I am wet but covered when her head pops through the dress hole and steps back in surprise and lets out a little French vowel, "Ah."
所以我一只眼睛盯着她，另一只眼睛盯着我的衬衫，它正从椅背上飘动。我靠得越来越近，双腿张得越来越开，只有我的头露出来。像条短吻鳄。看起来我在大约六英尺深的水中，但实际上只有约18英寸。我的大腿痛苦不堪，我无法再坚持了，当弗兰茨把裙子举过头顶时，我猛地从海滩上弹起，躲在椅子后面，我湿透了但遮住了，当她的头从裙孔钻出，惊讶地退后一步，发出一声轻微的法语元音，“啊”。
And we get dressed and we're walking across the cobblestones, back to the hotel, which are slightly uneven, so the backs of our hands brush. And she takes mine in hers. Which I've read in the Let's Go: Europe is a friendly and warm gesture among European women. Don't get any ideas. So I'm feeling friendly and warm, trying not to have any ideas. When Franz says, "Susan is very lucky to have you." And I say, "Well, thank you very much, but I'm very lucky to have her." Trying to regain a shred of dignity while holding onto this woman's hand.
我们穿上衣服，走过鹅卵石路回酒店，路面有点不平，所以我们的手背碰在了一起。她抓住了我的手。我在《Let's Go: Europe》里读到过，这是欧洲女性之间友好而温暖的姿势。别想歪了。所以我感觉友好而温暖，试图不产生任何想法。当弗兰茨说：“苏珊有你真是太幸运了。”我说：“嗯，非常感谢，但我有她也非常幸运。”在紧握这个女人的手时试图重拾一丝尊严。
James Braly.He's touring the country with a one-man show called Life in a Marital Institution , which he's also turning into a book. His website, jamesbraly-- that's B-R-A-L-Y-- dot com. Thanks, as always, to The Moth, which features personal stories told live in front of an audience. For more Moth stories, check out The Moth's great free weekly podcasts at themoth.org. And The Moth has started its own radio show, The Moth Radio Hour, which we welcome onto the scene, now on public radio stations around the country.
詹姆斯·布拉利。他正在全国巡演，演出名为《婚姻机构里的生活》，他也在将其改编成一本书。他的网站，jamesbraly——即B-R-A-L-Y——点com。一如既往，感谢“飞蛾”，它展示了在观众面前现场讲述的个人故事。想要更多飞蛾故事，请查看飞蛾每周出色的免费播客themoth.org。飞蛾已经开始了它自己的广播节目，《飞蛾广播时间》，我们欢迎它的加入，现在在全国的公共广播电台都能听到。
Act 3, "How did I get here?" So James Braly gave us the thoughts of somebody in a moment before infidelity occurs. Dani Shapiro has this story about the confusing mess it can be during the affair.
第三幕，“我怎么会到这儿？”詹姆斯·布拉利给了我们出轨发生前瞬间的想法。丹妮·夏皮罗讲述了这个外遇期间混乱困境的故事。
DANI SHAPIRO: Here, in no particular order, are some things Lenny told me. That he and his wife didn't sleep in the same bed. That they haven't had a real marriage in years. That she was undergoing electroshock treatment in a clinic outside Philadelphia. That he had cancer and had to fly to Houston three days a week for chemotherapy. That his youngest daughter, age three, had a rare form of childhood leukemia. That he could not get a divorce for all of the above reasons. That he was heartbroken that he could not leave his wife and marry me.
丹妮·夏皮罗：这里，顺序不分先后，是莱尼告诉我的一些事情。他和妻子不同床。他们已经多年没有真正的婚姻了。她在费城外的一家诊所接受电击治疗。他患有癌症，每周必须飞往休斯顿三次进行化疗。他最小的女儿，三岁，患有一种罕见的儿童白血病。由于上述所有原因，他无法离婚。他心碎于无法离开妻子并与我结婚。
For a long time I believed him, with every bone in my body I trusted that Lenny Klein was telling me the truth. When we talked about it, his jaw would tighten and his big brown eyes would fill with tears. His voice would quaver with pent-up, complex feelings that I couldn't possibly begin to understand. Poor Lenny. I marveled that so many bad things could happen to one person. And I vowed to take care of him. I exhorted myself to be a real woman, one who could step up to the plate and be good to her man in his moment of crisis.
很长一段时间我都在相信他，我骨子里信任莱尼·克莱因说的是真话。当我们谈论这件事时，他的下巴会紧绷，他棕色的大眼睛会充满泪水。他的声音会因压抑的、复杂的我无法开始理解的感受而颤抖。可怜的莱尼。我惊叹于一个人怎么会发生这么多糟糕的事情。我发誓要照顾他。我告诫自己要成为一个真正的女人，一个能够在危机时刻挺身而出、善待男人的女人。
Years later, I hold Lenny's lies up to the light and examine my own reasons for believing what, in retrospect, seems preposterous. I reread my old journals and noticed the way my girlish handwriting deteriorated into a scrawl as I wrote, "I have to be there for Lenny, he needs me, and he's going through so much. I don't know if I can handle it, but I have to be strong." I try to remember that Lenny was a trial lawyer, that he built an international reputation based on his own pathology. That he lied with an almost evangelical conviction. He prided himself on being able to convince anyone of anything.
多年后，我把莱尼的谎言放在光下审视，并检查我自己相信那些回顾起来似乎荒谬的事情的原因。我重读了我的旧日记，注意到我少女时代的字迹在我写下时变得潦草：“我必须在莱尼身边，他需要我，他经历了这么多。我不知道我是否能应付，但我必须坚强。”我试着记住莱尼是一名辩护律师，他基于自己的病态建立了国际声誉。他以一种近乎福音派的信念撒谎。他以能说服任何人相信任何事情而自豪。
The lies had small beginnings. Lenny called me from a business trip and told me he was at Montreal airport, waiting to catch a flight to Calgary. I checked with the airline and found out that the flight would take approximately five hours, so when Lenny called an hour later to say he had landed in Calgary, I very calmly asked him where he really was. "Calgary," he said. "No, Lenny. Really." He stuck to his story. In the time that I knew him, he never, ever changed his story midstream.
这些谎言都有小的开始。莱尼从出差途中给我打电话，告诉我他在蒙特利尔机场，等着赶往卡尔加里的航班。我查了一下航空公司，发现航班大约需要五个小时，所以当莱尼一小时后打电话说他已经在卡尔加里降落时，我非常平静地问他到底在哪里。“卡尔加里，”他说。“不，莱尼。真的。”他坚持他的说法。在我认识他的时间里，他从未，从未在中途改变过他的故事。
I hung up on him and called his family's house in Westchester. When the maid answered the phone, I asked to speak with Mr. Klein. And when he picked up the extension, and I heard his rough, craggy, "Hello," I screamed so hard into his ear that he dropped the receiver. He raced into the city, he let himself into my apartment and found me curled up in bed. He scooped me up and held me to his chest. His wife wasn't home, he told me. She was having shock treatment. And someone had to take care of his daughter.
我挂断了他的电话，打给了他在威彻斯特的家。女佣接了电话，我要求和克莱因先生谈谈。当他接起分机，我听到他那粗哑的“喂”声时，我对着他的耳朵尖叫得太大声，以至于他扔掉了听筒。他冲进城里，溜进我的公寓，发现我蜷缩在床上。他把我抱起来，贴在胸口。他告诉我，他妻子不在家。她正在接受电击治疗。而必须有人照顾他的女儿。
He hadn't wanted to tell me because he wanted to spare me, to protect me from the horror of his life. Surely I understood. "Shush, sweetheart," he murmured into the top of my head as I wept, my face beet red like a little girl's. "So many people need me," he said. "But I love you best of all."
他不想告诉我，因为他想保护我，让我免受他生活中恐怖的影响。肯定我理解。“嘘，亲爱的，”当我哭泣时，他对着我的头顶低语，我的脸像小女孩一样红得像甜菜。“很多人需要我，”他说。“但我最爱你。”
Two years have passed, and something has gone wrong, terribly wrong with my life. I don't, in fact, think of my life as my life, but rather as a series of random events that have no logical connection. I'm no longer a student. I dropped out of Sarah Lawrence after my junior year, supposedly to pursue acting. And I'm actually doing a pretty good imitation of an actress. But I'm doing an even better imitation of a mistress.
两年过去了，我的生活出了一些问题，出了严重的问题。事实上，我不再认为我的生活是我的生活，而是一系列没有任何逻辑联系的随机事件。我不再是学生了。大三后我从莎拉·劳伦斯学院辍学，据说为了追求表演。而且我实际上是在做一个相当好的演员模仿。但我做的更好的模仿是情妇。
Lenny's been busy buying me things. I don't particularly want these things, but they seem to be what Lenny is offering in lieu of himself. So quite suddenly, overnight really, I find myself driving a black Mercedes convertible. And just in case I might be mistaken for anything other than a kept woman, I wear a mink coat, a Cartier watch, a Bulgari necklace with an ancient coin at its center. The Mercedes is a step down from the first car Lenny gave me, when we had been going out for a month. A leased Ferrari. I don't know how to drive a stick shift, so the Ferrari was a bit of a problem. What I must have looked like, a 20-year-old blonde, dressed like Ivana Trump, stalled in traffic, grinding gears, trying to find the point on the clutch to hold that ridiculous car in place.
莱尼一直忙着给我买东西。我并不特别想要这些东西，但它们似乎是莱尼代替自己提供的补偿。所以突然间，几乎一夜之间，我发现自己在开一辆黑色奔驰敞篷车。以防我被误认为是除了被包养的女人以外的任何人，我穿着水貂皮大衣，戴着卡地亚手表，戴着中心有一枚古钱币的宝格丽项链。奔驰比莱尼给我买的第一辆车低了一个档次，那是在我们约会一个月后。一辆租赁的法拉利。我不会开手动挡，所以法拉利有点麻烦。我看起来一定很滑稽，一个20岁的金发女郎，打扮得像伊万娜·特朗普，停在交通中，磨损齿轮，试图找到离合器的点来保持那辆荒谬的车位。
Lenny rented an apartment on a pretty little street in Greenwich Village. A furnished triplex with a garden, a fireplace, and a bedroom with a four-poster bed. He called it "our house," as if he didn't have another home with a whole family in it an hour north of the city. He kept half a dozen suits in the bedroom closet, and a brand new silk robe hung behind the bathroom door. There was an entire floor we didn't use, a large airy children's nursery.
莱尼在格林威治村一条漂亮的小街上租了一套公寓。一套带有花园、壁炉和卧室里有一张四柱床的带家具的三层公寓。他称之为“我们的家”，好像他在城北一小时外没有另一个完整的家庭。他在卧室衣柜里放了半打西装，浴室门后挂着一件全新的丝绸长袍。有一整层楼我们没用，一间大的通风的儿童房。
My parents knew that something was up. They knew I was going out with somebody, but they had no idea who. I was drifting away from them, and they were letting me go. One night I invited them over for dinner. I pushed all traces of Lenny out of sight, but, of course, there were clues. A glossy brochure for Italian yachts. A humidor in the center of the coffee table.
我的父母知道出事了。他们知道我在和某人约会，但他们根本不知道是谁。我正在慢慢远离他们，而他们正任由我离去。一天晚上我邀请他们来吃晚饭。我把莱尼的所有痕迹都藏了起来，但当然，还是有线索。一本关于意大利游艇的精美宣传册。咖啡桌中心的一个雪茄盒。
I cooked up a storm and the place was filled with homey smells. Garlic, basil, coriander. It was winter, and the snow was piled up on the sills. Spotlights in the backyard shone on the landscaped garden, the redwood table, the Adirondack chairs. I had my father's favorite music, Dvorak's Symphony for the New World , playing on the stereo system.
我做了一顿大餐，房间里充满了家的味道。大蒜、罗勒、香菜。是冬天，窗台上堆满了积雪。后院的聚光灯照在景观花园、红木桌和阿迪朗达克椅上。我播放了父亲最喜欢的音乐，德沃夏克的《新世界交响曲》。
My parents rang the doorbell. They looked so solid standing on my front stoop, their cold, red noses poking out from above their mufflers. If nothing else, they looked like they belonged together. They were elegant and rangy, similarly proportioned. Unlike Lenny and me. Lenny's as thick as a linebacker, and I had become so delicate, the wind could have picked me up and blown me away.
我父母按了门铃。站在前门廊上的他们看起来如此稳重，冰冷、红红的鼻子露在围巾上方。至少，他们看起来像是属于彼此的。他们优雅而高挑，比例匀称。不像我和莱尼。莱尼像线卫一样粗壮，而我变得如此纤细，风都能把我吹走。
My mother strode into the brownstone as if it wasn't the weirdest thing in the world to be visiting her daughter in a lavish apartment with no name on the outside buzzer. My father trailed behind her wearily, as if setting foot on another planet. My mother entered the living room, flung her arms wide, and did an impromptu dance to Dvorak. "Tra-la-la-la," she trilled. My father and I hung back and watched, our faces crumpled into awkward smiles. It didn't occur to me that she was frightened. That this was a lot for her to take in, her college dropout daughter living in the lap of luxury.
我母亲大步走进棕色砂岩建筑，仿佛拜访她住在大公寓里且室外门铃上没名字的女儿并不是世界上最奇怪的事情。我父亲疲惫地跟在她后面，仿佛踏上了另一个星球。我母亲走进客厅，双臂张开，对着德沃夏克的音乐跳了一段即兴舞蹈。“啦-啦-啦-啦，”她轻哼道。父亲和我退缩着观看，我们的脸挤出尴尬的微笑。我没想到她很害怕。这让她接受起来很吃力，她辍学的女儿生活在奢侈的怀抱中。
All I could see was her outsized self, twirling around my living room in her fur coat and boots. I wanted a drink.
我能看到的只有她超大的自我，穿着皮草大衣和靴子在我客厅里旋转。我想喝一杯。
I poured two glasses of chardonnay for my parents and a large vodka for myself. I figured that if the vodka was in a water glass they wouldn't know the difference, especially if I drank it like it was water. My drinking had taken on a new urgency in the past few months. It was no longer a question of desire, but of need. I could not get through an evening like this without the armor of booze. I handed them their wine and directed them to the couch.
我为父母倒了两杯霞多丽，为自己倒了一大杯伏特加。我想如果伏特加在水杯里他们不会知道区别，特别是如果我像喝水一样喝它。我的饮酒在过去几个月里有了新的紧迫感。不再是欲望的问题，而是需要。没有酒精的盔甲，我无法度过这样的夜晚。我把酒递给他们，指引他们坐到沙发上。
On the coffee table, I had put out a plate of crudites and a bowl of olives. "Quite a place," my mother said brightly, her gaze darting around the room at the white brick fireplace with its wrought iron tools, the glass wall overlooking the garden, the soaring ceiling. My father stared at the fringe of the rug, glassy eyed. He needed to be as numbed as I did to get through this night. "Thanks," I murmured, as if she was paying me a compliment.
在咖啡桌上，我放了一盘生蔬菜和一碗橄榄。“真是个好地方，”我母亲明亮地说，目光在房间里打转，看着带有锻铁工具的白色砖壁炉、俯瞰花园的玻璃墙、高耸的天花板。我父亲呆滞地盯着地毯边缘。他也需要像我一样麻木才能度过这个夜晚。“谢谢，”我嘟囔着，仿佛她在夸奖我。
I checked on dinner, using the opportunity to gulp some wine from the open bottle in the fridge. Vodka and white wine was a combination I knew worked for me. If I stuck with the formula, things shouldn't be too bad in the morning. Especially if I wasn't eating, and I couldn't see myself eating. The music had stopped by the time we all sat at the dining room table, but I didn't notice then. If I had I would certainly have changed the tape, filled the air with something other than the tinny, lonely sound of our three forks scraping against plates.
我去检查晚餐，借机喝了几口冰箱里打开的瓶子里的酒。伏特加和白葡萄酒是我知道对我有效的组合。如果我坚持这个公式，早上应该不会太糟糕。特别是如果我不吃东西，而且我也没胃口。当我们都坐在餐桌旁时，音乐已经停了，但我当时没注意到。如果我注意到了，我肯定会换磁带，让空气中充满除了我们三把叉子刮盘子的那种单薄、孤独的声音之外的东西。
I pushed my chicken from one side of my plate to the other. My stomach clenched and growled in protest. It seemed that my parents and I, after 22 years in each other's company, had run out of things to say. I already knew their views on the political situation in Israel, and we couldn't discuss my school work, I was no longer in school. My father pressed a corner of his napkin to his lips and murmured something about the food being delicious. My mother agreed.
我把鸡肉从盘子的一边推到另一边。我的胃紧缩着，抗议着。似乎在陪伴了22年后，我和父母已经无话可说了。我已经知道他们对以色列政治局势的看法，而我们不能讨论我的学业，我已经不在学校了。父亲把餐巾的一角按在嘴唇上，嘟囔着说食物很美味。母亲表示同意。
"My wonderful daughter," she said, shaking her head. "You've turned into such a little homemaker." I looked at my parents across the table. Is that what they really thought? How could they just sit there? Some small piece of me wanted my father to fling me over his shoulder and carry me kicking and screaming to the car he had parked outside. I secretly wished that they would drive me home, deposit me in my childhood bedroom, and feed me chicken soup and Saltines. I wanted to start my life over again, but I didn't know how.
“我出色的女儿，”她说，摇着头。“你已经变成了一个小管家了。”我隔着桌子看着父母。他们真的是这么想的吗？他们怎么能就坐在那儿？我内心的一小部分希望父亲能把我扛在肩上，把我踢打尖叫着带到他停在外面的车里。我暗自希望他们能开车送我回家，把我安置在童年卧室里，喂我喝鸡汤和咸饼干。我想重新开始我的生活，但我不知道怎么做。
In the face of the most tangible proof that Lenny had been lying to me all these years, I remained with him. "My little girl is dying," he would say whenever I noticed the discrepancies in his stories. Or "My children's mother is having electroshock therapy." When I couldn't take my own confusion anymore-- Was Lenny lying to me? Was I going crazy?-- I decided to hire a detective to get to the bottom of it.
面对莱尼这些年来一直对我撒谎的最实质证据，我仍然和他在一起。“我的小女孩快死了，”每当我注意到他故事里的出入时，他都会这样说。或者“我孩子的妈妈正在接受电击治疗。”当我再也无法承受自己的困惑时——莱尼在对我撒谎吗？我疯了吗？——我决定雇一名侦探来查个水落石出。
By this time, my parents knew all about me and Lenny in theory, but it wasn't something we could talk about. When I think back to my younger self rifling through the New York City yellow pages in search of a private investigator, I feel like I'm watching a movie about someone else. A girl so clueless she really didn't know that her desire to hire a detective was all the answer she needed. I chose a detective agency based on nothing more than its good address, in the East 60s, a neighborhood filled with private schools and shrinks.
到这个时候，我父母在理论上对我和莱尼的事情都知道，但这并不是我们可以谈论的事情。当我回想起年轻时的自己翻阅纽约市黄页寻找私人侦探时，我觉得自己在看一部关于别人的电影。一个如此无知的女孩，她真的不知道她雇佣侦探的愿望就是她所需要的全部答案。我选择了一家侦探社，基于它良好的地址，在东60区，一个充满私立学校和心理医生的社区。
"This isn't what you think," I told the detective. "I'm in a relationship with a married man, and I want you to find out if my boyfriend is cheating on me with his wife." At this, his eyebrows shot up. "Come again?" "He claims his wife is in a mental hospital. He told me he hasn't been with her in years." "And you think he might be lying?" said the investigator. Did I see the laughter behind his eyes or is my memory supplying it now? Because I simply cannot imagine a middle-aged man listening to an earnest, over-dressed 22-year-old girl tell them that she thinks her boyfriend might still be sleeping with his wife. "Yes," I said.
“这不是你想的那样，”我告诉侦探。“我和一个已婚男人有关系，我想让你查查我的男朋友是否在和他的妻子欺骗我。”听到这里，他挑起了眉毛。“再说一遍？”“他说他妻子在精神病院。他告诉我他们已经多年没有在一起了。”“你觉得他可能在撒谎吗？”调查员说。我看到了他眼中的笑意还是记忆现在加上去的？因为我简直无法想象一个中年男人听着一个认真、打扮过头的22岁女孩告诉他们她认为男朋友可能还在和妻子睡觉。“是的，”我说。
Days later, I got the proof about Lenny's lies. In tears, I called my mother. "Oh, darling. I'm so sorry. Is there anything I can do?" "I don't think so." A pause. "Do you want me to call his wife?"
几天后，我得到了莱尼撒谎的证据。我含着泪给母亲打了电话。“哦，亲爱的。我很抱歉。我能做什么吗？”“我想不用。”停顿。“你要我给他妻子打电话吗？”
My mother and Mrs. Klein had met each other at a few school functions back when none of this could have struck anyone as a remote possibility. "Yes," I said. "Call her." "I'll do it right now," my mother said.
我母亲和克莱因夫人在学校的一些活动上见过面，那时这一切还没让人觉得遥不可及。“是的，”我说。“打电话给她。”“我现在就打，”母亲说。
I sat by the phone and watched the minutes tick by. I pictured Lenny's wife answering the phone with a chirpy hello, and my mother's slow, steady explanation of why she was calling. I had set in motion a chain of events which was now unstoppable. More than 20 minutes passed before my mother called me back. "Well, I did it," she said. "You talked to her?" The world felt unreal, hallucinatory.
我坐在电话旁，看着时间流逝。我想象着莱尼的妻子用轻快的声音接听电话，而我母亲稳重地解释为什么要打电话。我引发了一系列现在无法停止的事件。超过20分钟后，母亲才给我回电话。“好吧，我做了，”她说。“你跟她谈过了？”世界感觉不真实，有幻觉。
"Yes. She called me a liar. She told me she has a happy marriage to a man who travels a lot. That he's on his way to California. And I said, 'No, he's on his way to see my daughter.'" My mother sounded proud of herself, immersed in the drama of the moment. "How did she seem?" I asked. "What do you mean?" "Lenny's wife, was she angry?" "No," my mother said slowly. "She just didn't believe me, Dani."
“是的。她骂我是个骗子。她告诉我她和一位经常出差的丈夫婚姻幸福。他在去加利福尼亚的路上。我说，‘不，他在去见我女儿的路上。’”我母亲听起来很自豪，沉浸在当下的戏剧性中。“她看起来怎么样？”我问。“你什么意思？”“莱尼的妻子，她生气了吗？”“没有，”我母亲慢慢地说。“她只是不相信我，丹妮。”
I spent the rest of that day in a state of awful excitement. Something was going to happen. And when Lenny showed up that evening at the apartment we were still sharing in the West Village, I was ready. He put his bags down and gave me a hug. The phone rang. My mother had given Mrs. Klein the number at the apartment and suggested she find out for herself what her husband was up to. Lenny picked up the phone on the kitchen well. "Hello?"
我在那一天的余下时间里处于一种糟糕的兴奋状态中。有什么事要发生了。当莱尼那天晚上出现在我们还在西村合住的公寓时，我准备好了。他放下包，拥抱了我。电话响了。我母亲给了克莱因夫人公寓的电话号码，并建议她自己查查她丈夫在搞什么鬼。莱尼接起了厨房壁上的电话。“喂？”
I watched him. And for the first and only time in the years I knew him, he looked genuinely surprised. He didn't say a word. He just listened for a few minutes, then hung up the phone. "That was my wife," he said. I was silent. "How did she get this number?" I shrugged. "I have to go." "I'd imagine," I said faintly.
我看着他。在我认识他的那些年里，他第一次也是唯一一次看起来真的很惊讶。他一句话也没说。他只是听了几分钟，然后挂了电话。“那是我妻子，”他说。我沉默了。“她怎么得到这个号码的？”我耸耸肩。“我得走了。”“我想是这样，”我虚弱地说。
When Lenny slammed out of the apartment, I was certain I would never see him again. I knew the truth now. It was staring me in the face in the concrete form of flight lists and photos. And he knew that I knew. And besides, the whistle was blown. What could he possibly tell his wife? This was it, I told myself. Absolutely, positively the end.
当莱尼猛地摔门离开公寓时，我确信我再也见不到他了。我现在知道了真相。它以飞行名单和照片的具体形式呈现在我面前。他知道我知道。而且，吹哨了。他还能对他妻子说什么呢？我对自己说，这就是一切。绝对的、肯定的终点。
It wasn't the end. Lenny still called 10, 12 times a day. He left messages on my answering machine. "Hello?" His voice filled my bedroom. "Fox, are you there?" Sometimes he didn't say a word. He would stay on the line for as long as five minutes, just breathing. Eventually he did get to me again. And for the next year that we were together, three days here, four days there, my life became unrecognizable to me. I idly wondered what it would take to get me to leave him.
这不是终点。莱尼仍然每天打10、12次电话。他在我的留言机上留话。“喂？”他的声音充满了我的卧室。“狐狸，你在吗？”有时他一句话也不说。他会在电话线上待上五分钟，只是呼吸。最终他确实又联系上了我。在我们在一起的下一年里，这里三天，那里四天，我的生活对我来说变得无法辨认。我漫不经心地想，要花多少代价才能让我离开他。
I wondered about this over bottles of chilled white wine, or heavy glasses half-filled with scotch. I was still wondering about it when I went to stay for a while at a health spa in California. The phone rang in my room one day. There had been a car crash on a snowy highway. My mother had 80 broken bones. My father was in a coma. They were lying in a hospital 3,000 miles away. And suddenly, in ways I could not have imagined seconds earlier, nothing else mattered. As I packed my bags, I remembered my mother twirling, dancing to Dvorak, through the doors of Lenny's brownstone. And the glassy look in my father's eyes.
我在一瓶瓶冷冻的白葡萄酒，或半满威士忌的沉重玻璃杯中思考这个问题。当我搬到加利福尼亚的一家健康水疗中心住上一段时间时，我还在思考这个问题。一天我房间里的电话响了。雪地公路上发生了一起车祸。我母亲有80根骨头骨折。我父亲陷入昏迷。他们躺在3000英里外的医院里。突然之间，以我几秒前无法想象的方式，其他任何事情都无关紧要了。当我收拾行李时，我想起了母亲旋转着，伴随着德沃夏克的音乐，穿过莱尼棕色砂岩建筑大门。还有父亲眼中呆滞的神情。
I prayed that my father wouldn't die disappointed in me, and I knew then what I had to do.
我祈祷父亲不会失望地死去，而我知道我那时必须做什么。
Dani Shapiro. That story is in her memoir, Slow Motion . She has another book, Devotion , coming out in February.
丹妮·夏皮罗。那个故事在她的回忆录《慢动作》中。她还有另一本书《奉献》，二月份出版。
Act 4, "The Man Who Knew What I Was About to Say." So, in this second half of our program, we've had the moment before a possible affair, we've had what it's like during the affair, and now we turn to the aftermath of an affair. At least the very immediate aftermath. This story is by writer Etgar Keret, and read for us by actor Matt Malloy.
第四幕，“知道我要说什么的男人。”所以，在我们节目的后半部分，我们经历了可能发生外遇前的时刻，经历了外遇期间的感受，现在我们转向外遇的后果。至少是非常直接的后果。这个故事由作家埃特加·凯雷特撰写，由演员马特·马洛伊为我们朗读。
The man who knew what I was about to say sat next to me on the plane, a stupid smile plastered across his face. That's what's so nerve wracking about him. Smart, he wasn't. Or sensitive either. But still, he knew those lines and managed to say them. All the lines I meant to say, three seconds before me. "Do you sell Guerlain Mystique?" he asked the flight attendant, a minute before I could. And she gave him an orthodontic smile and said, "There's just one last bottle left." "My wife goes crazy for that perfume," he said. "She's positively addicted. If I come back from a trip without a bottle of Mystique from the duty free, she says I don't love her anymore. If I dare come into the house without at least one of these, I'm in deep [BLEEP]."
那个知道我要说什么的男人坐在我旁边的飞机上，脸上涂着愚蠢的微笑。这就是他最让我紧张的地方。他不聪明。也不敏感。但尽管如此，他知道那些台词，并设法说了出来。所有我打算在三秒前说的台词。“你卖娇兰秘境吗？”他问空姐，比我能问的时间早了一分钟。她给了他一个牙套微笑说：“只剩下最后一瓶了。”“我妻子对那种香水很着迷，”他说。“她简直上瘾了。如果我从旅行回来时没有带一瓶免税店的秘境，她说她就不再爱我了。如果我敢在没有至少带一瓶这种香水的情况下回家，我就死定了[哔——]。”
That was supposed to be my line, but the man who knew what I was about to say stole it from me, without missing a beat. As soon as the wheels touched the ground, he switched on his mobile, a second before I did, and called his wife. "I just landed," he told her. "I'm sorry. I know it was supposed to be yesterday, flight was canceled. You don't believe me? Check it out yourself. Call Eric. I know you don't. I can give his number right now."
那本该是我的台词，但那个知道我要说什么的男人从我这里偷走了它，甚至没有停顿一下。轮子刚接触地面，他立刻打开了手机，比我早一秒，给他的妻子打电话。“我刚落地，”他告诉她。“对不起。我知道应该是昨天，航班被取消了。你不相信我？你自己查查。给埃里克打电话。我知道你不信。我现在就能给你他的电话。”
I also have a travel agent called Eric. He'd lie for me, too.
我也有一个叫埃里克的旅行社代理人。他也会为我撒谎。
When the plane reached the gate he was still talking on his mobile, giving all the answers I would have given, without a trace of emotion. Like a parrot in a world where time flows backwards, repeating whatever is about to be said instead of what's been said already. His answers were the best ones, under the circumstances. His circumstances weren't too hot, not too hot at all. Mine weren't either. Nobody was answering my call.
当飞机到达登机口时，他还在用手机通话，说着我本来会给出的所有答案，没有任何情感痕迹。就像一个时间倒流的世界里的鹦鹉，重复着即将说出的东西，而不是已经说过的。在那种情况下，他的回答是最好的。他的情况不太好，一点也不好。我的也不好。没有人接听我的电话。
But just listening to the man who knew what I was about to say made me stop trying. Just listening to him, I could tell that this was a hole that even if I dug my way out of, it would be to a different reality. She'd never forgive me. She'd never trust me. Ever. All my coming trips would be hell on earth, and the time in between would be even worse. He went on talking and talking and talking. All those sentences that I'd thought up and hadn't said yet. It just kept flowing.
但仅仅听着那个知道我要说什么的男人说话，我就停止了尝试。仅仅听着他，我就能看出这是一个即便我拼命挖坑爬出去，也会通往不同现实的洞。她永远不会原谅我。她永远不会信任我。永远。我未来所有的旅行都会是人间地狱，而这期间的时间会更糟。他继续说着，说着，说着。所有那些我想出却还没说的句子。它就这样不断流出。
He stepped it up, changing the intonation, like a drowning man struggling desperately to stay afloat. People began getting off. He got up, still talking, scooped up his laptop in the other hand and headed for the exit. I could see him forgetting it behind, the bag he had put in the overhead compartment. I could see him forgetting it. I didn't say anything. I just stayed put.
他加快了语速，改变了语调，就像一个垂死挣扎的人为了保持漂浮而拼命努力。人们开始下机。他站起来，还在说话，另一只手抓起笔记本电脑，朝着出口走去。我可以看到他把它忘在后面了，他放在行李架上的包。我可以看到他把它忘了。我什么也没说。我只是坐着不动。
Gradually everyone walked out, till the only ones still there were an overweight religious woman with a million children and me. I got up and opened the overhead compartment above me, as if nothing. I took out the duty free bag like it had always been mine. Inside were the receipt and the bottle of Guerlain Mystique. My wife goes crazy for that perfume. She's positively addicted. If I come back from a trip without a bottle of Mystique from the duty free, she says I don't love her anymore.
渐渐地所有人都走了，直到唯一留在那里的是一个带着一百万个孩子的肥胖宗教女性和我。我站起来，像什么都没发生一样打开了上面的行李架。我拿出那袋免税商品，就好像它一直都是我的。里面是收据和那瓶娇兰秘境。我妻子对那种香水很着迷。她简直上瘾了。如果我从旅行回来时没有带一瓶免税店的秘境，她说她就不再爱我了。
Matt Malloy, reading a story by Etgar Keret, who is the author of several books of very, very short stories, most recently The Girl on the Fridge.
马特·马洛伊，朗读了埃特加·凯雷特的故事，他是几本非常、非常短的故事集的作者，最近的一本是《冰箱上的女孩》。
Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and our senior producer Julie Snyder with Alex Blumberg, Jane Marie, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, and Alissa Shipp. Production help from Erin Scott. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Our music consultant is Jessica Hopper. Special thanks today to The Moth and to Paul Tough.
我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克和资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、简·玛丽、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩和阿丽莎·希普参与。制作帮助来自艾琳·斯科特。塞斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。我们的音乐顾问是杰西卡·霍珀。今天特别感谢“飞蛾”和保罗·托夫。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ for our program by our boss Torey Malatia. I'm a happily married man, so does it mean anything when he swims over to me at the company retreat and says things like, "The water makes me feel so free." I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ为我们的节目提供了支持，我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚。我是一个婚姻幸福的男人，那么当他在公司静修时游过来对我说是诸如“水让我感到如此自由”之类的话时，这有什么意义吗？我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。